Cara Delevingne comes forward claiming
Harvey Weinstein sexually harassed her
[Music]
in a statement posted to her Instagram
Wednesday the model details her alleged
experience with the movie mogul claiming
he threatened her career over her sexual
orientation quote he said to me that if
I was gay I'd never get the role of a
straight woman or make it as an actress
in Hollywood the 25 year old who has
publicly said she is quote sexually
fluid claims that a few years after that
initial conversation she was invited to
Weinstein's hotel room for a meeting
where he allegedly asked her to kiss
another woman in front of him when des
Levine said she had to leave she claims
he walked her to the door and tried to
kiss her on the lips but she quote
stopped him and managed to get out of
the room the paper town star still went
on to appear in a film he produced in
2014 tulip fever but says she's felt
guilty ever since quote I want women and
girls to know that being harassed or
abused or raped is never their fault des
Levine added that she feels quote
relieved to open up like this the more
we talk about it the less power we give
them des Levine is the latest in a
string of Hollywood actresses alleging
that Weinstein had sexually harassed
them following the New York Times
initial article last Friday which
accused the producer of sexual
misconduct for three decades in a
statement to ET Weinstein's lawyer
Charles J harder called the New York
Times report quote saturated with false
and defamatory statements
[Music]
you